i don't see where uh
the uh awareness that we're aware
the the heart problem doesn't feel like
it's solved i mean they they're they're
it it's called a hard problem for a
reason because
it seems like there needs to be a major
leap
yeah i think the major leap is to
understand how it is possible that a
machine can dream
that the physical system
is able to create a representation that
the physical system is acting on and
that is spun force and so on but once
you accept the fact that you are not in
physics but that you exist inside of the
story i think the mystery disappears
everything is possible in a statement
exists inside the story okay so your
consciousness is being written into the
story the fact that you experience
things is written to the story you ask
yourself is this real what i'm seeing
and your brain writes into the story yes
it's real
so what about the perception of
consciousness so to me you look
conscious
so
the illusion of consciousness the
demonstration of consciousness
i ask for the
the legged robot how do we make this
legged robot conscious
so
there's two things and maybe you can
tell me if they're neighboring ideas
one is actually make it conscious
and the other is make it appear
conscious to others
are those related
let's ask from the other direction what
would it take to make you not conscious
so
when you are thinking about how you
perceive the world
can you decide to
switch from looking at qualia
to looking at representational states
and it turns out you can yeah there is a
particular way in which you can
look at the world and recognize its
machine nature including your own
and in that state you don't have that
conscious experience in this way anymore
it becomes
apparent as a representation everything
becomes opaque
and i think this thing that you
recognize everything as a representation
this is typically what we mean with
enlightenment states
and yeah you can have a motivational
level but you can also do this on the
experiential level and the perceptual
level see but then i can come back to a
conscious state
i okay i particularly
i'm referring to the
social aspect that the demonstration of
consciousness
is a really nice thing at a party when
you're trying to meet a new person
it's a nice thing to to to know that
they're conscious and they can um
how i don't know how fundamental
consciousness is in human interaction
but it seems like to be at least
uh an important part
and i i ask that in the same kind of way
for robots
you know in order to create a rich
compelling human robot interaction it
feels like there needs to be elements of
consciousness within that interaction
my cat is obviously conscious
and
so my cat can do this party trick she
also knows that i am conscious be able
to have feedback about the fact that we
are both acting on models of our own
awareness the question is how hard is it
for
uh the robot
artificially created robot to achieve
cat level in
st
party tricks yes so the issue for me is
currently not so much on how to build a
system that creates a story about a
robot that lives in the world
but to make an adequate representation
of the world
and the model model that you and me have
is a unified one it's verb one where you
basically make sense of everything that
you can perceive every feature in the
world that enters your perception can be
relationally mapped to a unified model
of everything
and we don't have an ai that is able to
construct such a unified model yet
so you need that unified model to do the
party trick yes i think that uh you it
doesn't make sense if this thing is
conscious but not in the same universe
as you because you could not relate to
each other
so what's the process would you say of
engineering consciousness in the machine
like what are the ideas here
so uh you probably want to have some
kind of perceptual system this
perceptual system is a processing agent
that is able to track sensory data and
predict the next frame and the sensory
data from the
previous frames of the sensory data in
the current state of the system so the
current state of the system is
perception instrumental to predicting
what happens next
and this means you build lots and lots
of functions that take all the blips
that you feel on your skin and that you
see on your retina or that you hear
and
puts them into a set of relationships
that allows you to predict what kind of
sensory data what kind of sensor of
blips your vector of blips you're going
to proceed in the next frame right this
is tuned and it's uh constantly tuned
until it gets as accurate as it can
you build a very accurate prediction
mechanism
that is step one of the perception so
first you predict then you perceive and
see the error in your prediction and you
have to do two things to make that
happen one is you have to build a
network of relationships that are
constraints
that uh
take all the variants in the world to
put each of the variances into a
variable variable that is connected with
relationships to other variables and
these relationships are computable
functions that constrain each other so
when you see a nose that points a
certain direction in space you have a
constraint that says there should be a
face nearby that has the same direction
right and if that is not the case you
have some kind of contradiction that you
need to resolve because it's probably
not the nose what you're looking at it
just looks like one so you have to
reinterpret the data and until you get
to a point where your model converges
and this process of making the sensory
data fit into your model structure is
what prg calls
the assimilation and accommodation is
the change of the models where you
change your model such a way that you
can assimilate everything
so you're you're talking about building
a hell of an awesome perception system
that's able to do prediction and
perception and correct and improving
wait just uh
the contradictions in the model yes and
of course it's very easy to make a model
in which you minimize the contradictions
just by allowing that it can be in many
many possible states right so if you
increase the degrees of freedom you will
have fewer contradictions but you also
want to reduce the degrees of freedom
because degrees of freedom mean
uncertainty
you want your model to reduce
uncertainty as much as possible
but reducing uncertainty is expensive so
you have to have a trade-off between
minimizing contradictions and reducing
uncertainty and you have only a finite
amount of compute and experimental time
and effort available to reduce
uncertainty in the world so you need to
assign value to what you observe
so you need some kind of motivational
system that is estimating what you
should be looking at and what you should
be thinking about it how you should be
applying your resources to model what
that is
right so you need to have something like
convergence links that tell you how to
get from the present state of the model
to the next one you need to have these
compatibility links that tell you which
constraints exist and which constraint
violations exist and uh you need to have
some kind of motivational system that
tells you what to pay attention to so
now we have a second agent next to the
perceptual age we have a motivational
agent
this is a cybernetic system that is
modeling what the system needs what's
important for the system and that
interacts with the perceptual system to
maximize the expected reward
and you're saying a motivational system
is some kind of
like what is it a higher level narrative
over some lower level it's just your
brainstem stuff the limbic system stuff
that tells you okay now you should get
something to eat because i've just
measured your blood sugar like
motivational system like the lower
levels yes like hungry yes but there's
basically a physiological needs and some
cognitive needs and some social needs
and they all interact and they're all
implemented at different parts in your
nervous system as the motivational
system but they're basically cybernetic
feedback loops it's not that complicated
it's just a lot of code
and
so you now have a motivational agent
that makes your robot go for the ball or
that makes your worm go to eat
food and so on and you have the
perceptual system that lets it predict
that environment so it's able to solve
that control problem to some degree
and now what we learned is that it's
very hard to build a machine learning
system that looks at all the data
simultaneously to see what kind of
relationships could exist between them
so you need to selectively model the
world you need to figure out where can i
make the biggest difference if i would
put the following things together
sometimes you find a gradient for that
right when you have a gradient you don't
need to remember where you came from you
just follow the gradient until it
doesn't get any better but if you have a
word where the problems are
discontinuous and the search spaces are
discontinuous you need to retain memory
of what you explored and you need to
construct a plan of what to explore next
and this thing that means that you have
next to this perceptual construction
system and the motivational cybernetics
an agent that is paying attention to
what it should select at any given
moment to maximize reward and this
scanning system this attention agent
is required for consciousness and
consciousness it is its control model
so it's the index memories that this
thing retains when it manipulates the
perceptual representations
to
maximize the value and minimize the
conflicts and it to increase coherence
so the purpose of consciousness is to
create coherence in your perception
representations remove conflicts predict
the future construct counterfactual
representations so you can coordinate
your actions and so on
and in order to do this it needs to form
memories these memories are partial
binding states of the working memory
contents that are being revisited later
on to backtrack to undo certain states
to look for alternatives and these index
memories that you can recall that is
what you perceive as your stream of
consciousness
and being able to recall these memories
this is what makes you conscious if you
could not remember what you paid
attention to you wouldn't be conscious
so consciousness is the index in the
memory database okay
you